es lo que más quiero me siento horrible
no le pedimos dinero a table este tipo
de personas necesitamos el dinero hay
cosas que pagar por favor necesito que
lo entiendas
bienvenidos a stack
donde cada voto cuenta hoy 5 parejas
deben decidir quién se llevará mil
dólares los jugadores tendrán cuatro
rondas para discutir y después de cada
una podrán votar en secreto un lingote
de oro equivale a un voto al final del
juego la pareja con la pila más alta
ganará el premio
esto es stacks
ah
cómo se sienten
y creo que están emocionados primera
ronda cada jugador recibirá un gota de
oro tendrán seis minutos para discutir
quién creen que debería llevarse al
premio cuando acabe el tiempo se les
explicará cómo votar en sus marcas
listos ya están casados nosotros si
nosotros no vayan ryan y yo estudiamos a
tiempo completo así que no nos vemos muy
seguido
nuestras citas suelen ser en el comedor
donde estudian la universidad del sur de
california
es obvio que sus padres los ayudan no le
pedimos dinero a paz y no somos ese tipo
de personas nos casamos en 2020 durante
la cuarentena así que no pudimos
celebrar nuestra boda por eso queremos
ganarnos el dinero lo usaríamos para
pasar tiempo juntos y también para
organizar la ceremonia queríamos hablar
primero para no sentir tanta presión
después así y tal vez nos recordaría ni
podríamos ganar eso sería genial
lo siento mucho pero este año no ha sido
nada fácil para ambos debo pagar mis
préstamos estudiantiles y muchas otras
deudas también este año perdí mi trabajo
y tuvimos que solicitar pensiones al
estado y ya todo se acabó de verdad nos
vendría muy bien cualquier ayuda mis
padres pasaron por un divorcio
complicado hace dos años y desde que
tengo 15 he trabajado más de 36 horas
por semana mientras estudio creo que
merecemos el dinero porque con todas las
horas que uso para trabajar o estudiar
hace que sea difícil para nosotros
vernos seguidos nos haría bien viajar o
hacer algo parecido mi esposa si es
enfermera cuando se gradúa lo primero
que tuvo que enfrentar fue el kobe y fue
muy difícil estar separados además no
pudimos usar el dinero de la luna de
miel porque debimos ayudar a nuestra
familia en las filipinas era difícil
y él se acabó el tiempo
es momento de votar y cada pareja votará
por quienes creen que debería ganar pero
hay una condición si todos votan por
ellos mismos el juego termina y nadie
gana
[Música]
todos tienen dificultades pero siento
que nuestra historia combina las de
ellos
[Música]
su mamá vive en filipinas y ella atendió
enfermos en 2020 claro se lo merece
[Música]
si está cuarto
es por eso que queremos que reciban este
dinero que sea como una bendición
entiendes
si está bien
charly a ver me conmovieron no han
tenido un camino fácil por eso voté por
ellos
creo que todos votaron por sí mismos y
decidimos no hacerlo para que el juego
pudiera continuar además me caen bien
son geniales
abran sus ojos
[Música]
ahí lo tienen no tenemos
continuamos
en la segunda ronda solo las parejas que
tienen lingotes recibirán dos más para
votar pero todas las parejas pueden
participar en la discusión listos creo
que votaremos por ustedes nuestras
historias se parecen mucho por eso
queremos apoyarlos también eres
enfermero y mi esposa sabe lo que eso
significa en cuanto a charly y amber
también gastamos nuestros ahorros porque
queríamos ayudar a la familia cuando
trajimos a nuestra abuela hice que me
ayudara con la propuesta de matrimonio
para ashly trajo un vídeo eso me
sorprendió
muy bien nosotros tuvimos un accidente
hace poco nos estamos recuperando y
hacemos terapia física me alegra que
estén bien
ustedes y por eso están aquí hoy
con estos lingotes
queremos aumentar nuestro historial
crediticio para finalmente poder
comprar cosas como estamos hablando de
salud estoy estudiando para ser
asistente médico si todo sale bien este
año me graduaré muy pronto y podré
especializarme pero eso me costará mucho
dinero el sueño podría ayudarme a pagar
parte de mis prestan tengo muchas ganas
de ampliar con alguien y siento que la
discusión no va a ningún lado todos
estamos compartiendo la historia de
nuestras vidas y necesito más emoción
por el divorcio complicado de mis padres
tuve que pagar la hipoteca de mi casa no
me molesta porque tengo un mejor hogar
ahora y ambos nos sentimos mejor que
antes sin embargo tuve que pedirle
prestado dinero a francisco para pagar
la hipoteca
lo amo mucho porque sé que cuando las
cosas se ponen difíciles siempre puedo
contar con él para apoyarme en esta
ronda las parejas pueden usar sus
lingotes para votar por otra incluso por
quienes no tienen
[Música]
bueno todos
aquí
[Música]
su historia me
conmovió porque sé lo difícil que es
tener problemas financieros y querer
ayudar a tus padres
ellos votarán por nosotros y queremos
hacer lo mismo por ellos
[Música]
quiero que ellos sigan jugando porque
los amo
nos sentimos identificados con su
historia los amamos
por favor abran los ojos
[Música]
en total
cuando estoy sentado me siento como esos
idiotas millonarios del juego del
calamar
con este atuendo listo para verlos para
tratarnos bien ahora en la tercera ronda
vamos a subir el nivel les toca decidir
que pareja quieren que pierda su pila
no tengo corazón para hacerlo
listos empiecen yo
me alegra que ellos regresaron a
todos y qué les parece si cada uno de
nosotros dice en que usaríamos el dinero
inmediatamente hace poco nos mudamos
cerca de la universidad así que
usaríamos el dinero para pagar el primer
mes de alquiler entiendo
intentaríamos comprar un auto nosotros
pensábamos en dividirlo yo usaría mi
parte para pagar la deuda de la hipoteca
de mi madre así podría ahorrar algo de
dinero de mi salario para el próximo mes
y así pagar por mis clases del semestre
nos ha pasado eso hemos dicho
necesitamos el dinero en cosas que pagar
es una situación complicada si usamos
nuestro dinero para ayudar a la familia
pero queremos tener nuestra luna de miel
porque queremos comenzar una familia a
finales de este año intentaré ser breve
estoy seguro de una cosa y es que
estamos aquí por una razón nosotros
perdimos familiares ustedes velan por
los suyos también tuvimos un accidente
de auto en 2017 pero ahora estamos
estudiamos y sabemos lo difícil que es y
usted es nuestro entorno familiar
tampoco fue mejor conocemos el dolor que
sienten usaríamos parte del dinero para
aprender a invertir porque las
dificultades financieras separaron a
nuestros padres y quisiéramos no nos
sentiríamos bien quedándonos con todo el
dinero por eso tomaríamos una parte y la
repartiríamos entre todos
las parejas con lingotes votarán por
aquella que creen que debería perder
toda su pila
[Música]
debemos elegir si ganamos les daremos
dinero a todos vamos a pedirles sus
cuentas de paypal tal vez así nadie
votará por nosotros y pasaremos de ronda
siento que sus necesidades no son
inmediatas creo que todos votamos por
nicole y ashley vinimos por los mil
dólares y no vamos a recogernos todavía
pero los queremos abran los ojos en
lo veía venir tenía sentido y lo
entiendo nicole y ashley perdieron su
pila pero ahora pueden distribuir sus
cinco tes y dárselos a cualquiera de las
parejas participantes
[Música]
cielos fue bastante parejo pero parece
que hay y francisco van a la delantera
no esperaba que a todas las parejas les
importaran nuestros problemas
es la ronda final tienen dos minutos
para discutir pero todavía no les voy a
decir cómo votarán en esta ocasión
empieza les gustaría decir algo personal
deberíamos ser estratégicos podríamos
a eso puede estar de acuerdo hagamos
hablaremos en melaza desde que lo
conozco
siempre ha querido visitar las montañas
y ver nieve en persona además del
alquiler ya estaríamos el dinero en una
cita que no sea verdad es que no pudimos
votar por ninguno de ustedes así que
votamos por nosotros cuando dijimos que
distribuiría mos el dinero entre todos
era en serio le dijimos a la cámara que
le pediríamos sus cuentas si ganamos
todos ganan es un lindo gesto pero
estamos aquí para amargarle ganar todo
el dinero nuestro auto quedó destruido
necesitamos comprar una nueva gracias
por sus votos chicos tranquilos
queremos ayudarlos de alguna manera con
que no sea mucho nosotros empezaremos
una familia por eso el dinero nos
vendría bien aunque serían como tres
tanques de gasolina
esta es la última regla para las
votaciones las parejas deberán mover un
lingote de una pila a otra sólo aquellas
que tengan una pila pueden participar
no lo sé
pensé que lo mejor era quitarle uno a la
pareja que tiene más y dárselo a la
pareja que no tiene
sí
[Música]
pero necesito que lo entiendas no quiero
quitarles el dinero a ellos porque
quieren comprar un auto y lo necesitan
no quiero quitarles a ellos el dinero
porque quieren comprar una casa
deberíamos quitarles el dinero a ellos
que quieren ir a cenar
muy bien
eso es abran los ojos en
[Música]
como pueden ver yo hay un empate me
sorprendió no lo esperaba charly y amber
hype y francisco no lo creo esto es lo
que pasará tendrán 30 segundos para
discutir y luego cada pareja deberá
mover un lingote de las pilas empatadas
si hay otro empate el juego termina aquí
y nadie gana no quiero que parezca que
sus problemas son menos importantes que
los nuestros pero creo que merecemos el
dinero porque no tenemos otro apoyo para
nosotros mi papá ya no está en mi vida y
sus padres trabajan a tiempo completo
para proveer a sus cuatro hermanos creo
que lo más importante es que queremos
ayudar a todos estaba sacando cuentas en
mi cabeza
tal vez podemos darles 100 no podría ser
sino 50 sé que tal vez no sea mucho pero
nos gustaría ayudar a todos así todos
ganamos sabemos que ustedes lo merecen
tanto como cualquier otro no podemos
creer en lo que dicen no los conozco
pero parecen buenas personas no escucha
me tengo que explicar mucho algo por
favor escuchad a opción un haba
ellos toman uno y se lo llevan y
nosotros hacemos lo mismo opción 2
tomamos uno nuestro y se lo damos porque
ellos ya tomaron uno y se supone que van
a dividir el dinero entre todos antes de
quedarse con una parte de cualquier
forma nos llevaríamos algo de dinero no
necesitamos mucho recuerda lo que opinas
y sí sí
[Música]
todos ellos merecen el dinero
sí sí hay otro empate el juego terminará
y nadie se llevará el premio bien abran
sus ojos en
321 ahora
[Música]
es una lástima pero hubo otro empate así
que nadie se llevará el dinero me siento
horrible
sabía que nadie ganaría porque ambos
tienen situaciones que les exigen dinero
esperábamos que a francisco tiffany ryan
son mike a nicole y ashley pudieran
llevar si algo no quiero llorar de nuevo
pero creo que se acerca mi marido cuando
entramos y vi llegar a todas las parejas
al estudio pensé cielos deben tener
buenos empleos salarios altos pero luego
escuché sus historias y vendí que vaya
tenemos más en común de lo que pensaba
al principio eso es todo gracias por ver
el vídeo el grupo no está nada contento
porque nadie gana hoy pero yo me quedaré
con los mil dólares
si la pasaron bien denle un me gusta al
vídeo y comenten gracias por venir fue
un gusto ser ha llegado un aplauso
nos vemos la próxima vez